oh yeah global citizens our grand vision
at real-life English is to create a
world beyond borders to help you connect
your English learning to the
life-changing realization that no matter
what our nation our culture or our
language no matter what divides us what
unites us is far greater today we're
gonna guide you through one of the most
epic YouTube videos about this exact
topic ever it's called the big picture
by jason silva from a youtube channel
called shots of awe to look at the big
picture is to zoom out and look at
things from a higher perspective the
English Jason uses in this video is
quite poetic but very advanced but to
help we created a free downloadable PDF
lesson that not only provides a
transcript but it also breaks down all
the most important vocabulary we've also
linked some other phenomenal shots of
awe videos you can download that on the
link in the upper right corner or in the
information box below there's a great
anecdote about the very first photograph
taken of Earth from the vantage point of
space the idea was that this photograph
occasioned a profound shift in our
understanding of ourselves you see for
the first time in human history we could
look back at our planet in its entirety
and see the big picture
this provided an ontological awakening
it changed our story our narrative it
upgraded our self image it expanded our
consciousness new maps for new realities
as they say there's a great anecdote
about the very first photograph taken of
Earth from the vantage point of space
an anecdote is a popular story while
Vantage plant means point of view so
he's saying there's a story about the
first photograph taken from the
perspective of space the idea was at
this photograph occasion the profound
shift in our understanding of ourselves
to occasion is a very poetic way to say
to cause well to shift is to pass
through a sudden and unilateral change
for example the common term paradigm
shift is a rapid fundamental change in
your perspective this video definitely
causes a paradigm shift for people this
provided an ontological awakening it
changed our story our narrative it
upgraded our self-image ontological is a
very academic term that signifies the
fundamental nature of being or human
nature an upgrade is a systematic
improvement on something for example you
can upgrade your computer operating
system but here he is saying that when
humans looked at the Earth from space
for the first time we the human race
upgraded our self-image the way we see
and understand ourselves there's a great
anecdote about the very first photograph
taken of Earth from the vantage point of
space the idea was that this photograph
occasioned a profound shift in our
understanding of ourselves you see for
the first time in human history we could
look back at our planet in its entirety
and see the big picture this provided an
ontological awakening it changed our
story our narrative it upgraded our
self-image it expanded our consciousness
new maps for new realities as they said
astronauts in orbit call this experience
the overview effect a boundary
shattering sense of revelation and
global interconnectedness where we shake
off our petty differences and emerge
with a sense of global responsibility
colville consciousness in global
citizenship astronauts in orbit call
this experience the overview effect to
be in orbit is to move on a path around
an object in space and while the literal
meaning of overviews of review or
summary the overview effect is the
profound change in consciousness that
happens when astronauts see the planet
as one without borders from the outside
a boundary shattering sense of
Revelation and global interconnectedness
he describes this experience as boundary
shattering to shatter is to break all at
once for example a glass shatters when
it hits the ground in boundary is like a
limit or border that separates things a
boundary shattering sense of global
interconnectedness where we shake off
our petty differences in this case shake
off means to remove for example a dog
shakes off water after getting wet and
petty means small and not important
astronauts in orbit call this experience
the overview effect a boundary
shattering sense of Revelation and
global interconnectedness where we shake
off our petty differences and emerge
with a sense of global responsibility
global consciousness in global
citizenship Carl Sagan's famous pale
blue dot film echoed the same idea from
the vantage point of space there are no
lines dividing nations no geographical
subdivisions no flags or racial divides
or disputed territory
there is only earth a single celestial
body teeming with life the womb in which
we dwell Carl Sagan's famous pale blue
dot film echoed the same idea pale blue
dot is a famous photograph of the Earth
taken from the Voyager space probe in
1990 from the rings of Saturn as you can
see it shows our planet as a pale blue
dot in the vast expanse of the universe
a pale dot is a small mark that lacks
color in this video Jason is referring
to Carl Sagan's a pat short poem which
you can find on YouTube and we will
share it at the end of this video
echo is to repeat or reflect a sound or
an idea for example my voice echoes in
the Grand Canyon
there is only earth a single celestial
body teeming with life the womb in which
we dwell celestial means to be
positioned in the sky relative to space
and two-team means to be filled with
something and overflowing teeming with
life a womb is the place that something
is generated the part of a woman's body
where the baby develops before birth and
sits well is a more poetic synonym for
the verb to live Carl Sagan's famous
pale blue dot film echoed this same idea
from the vantage point of space there
are no lines dividing nations no
geographical subdivisions no flags or
racial divides or disputed territory
there is only earth a single celestial
body teeming with
the womb in which we dwell yet the fact
is our historically myopic point of view
or certainly our limited perspective has
resulted in much animosity we have all
too often organized ourselves into
competing hostile tribes subjugating
each other for land and resources and
misrepresenting the big picture into a
story of borders subdivisions and
dividing lines too much hostility and
not enough empathy and compassion
cultural differences religion tribes
nation race these are creative
expressions and variations that should
and could be celebrated instead they
become symbols that are all too often
used to create suffocating boundaries
and they are increasingly ill-conceived
to address the challenges of a
hyper-connected global world as
advancements in technology and
information enable greater mobility of
ideas goods and people the role of the
physical border is shifting and due for
an upgrade conflicts remain and too many
people are restricted access to the
increasingly fluid means of migration
transportation and movement migration
has always been a defining factor of the
human experience migration has and
continues to touch all nations cultures
and regions all peoples on the planet
migration has been the seed at the heart
of thriving societies accelerating the
dissemination of knowledge and ideas
restricting migration is ultimately like
restricting the flow of ideas in much
the same way that we don't tolerate
censorship or book-burning we might
consider the ways in which restricting
the free movement of people can be
equally punishing to the idea of human
flourishing the desire to become a
global citizen is human we all have it
and we all share the same goals for
safety comfort and prosperity for our
family
some are fortunate enough to be able to
invest in the second residence and
citizenship while others are forced to
seek asylum their survival being a
global citizen is also about the strong
and the wealthy helping the weak and the
poor as we saw with the global citizen
tax initiative border disputes conflict
zones armed borders these are things
that persist and need to be addressed we
need a new story a new lens with which
to address these inconsistencies we need
to scale up to unleash a truly global
citizenry exchanging ideas beliefs goods
and services it has been said that
empathy rarely extends beyond our line
of sight and so perhaps it is by
extending our gaze we need a new story a
new lens with which to address these
inconsistencies a lens is literally the
glass you see through to improve your
vision but cameras and telescopes also
have lenses your lens for the world
could be considered your worldview or
belief system we need to scale up to
unleash a truly global citizenry to
unleash is to release something powerful
from being restrained or captive quite
literally here's a dog wearing a leash
this is maybe where the words come from
because to take a leash off would be to
unleash it global citizenry is a belief
that we are all part of a shared global
community almost like a nation that
contains the entire planet it has been
said that empathy rarely extends beyond
our line of sight and so perhaps it is
by extending our gaze beyond is on the
other side of something
for example our grand vision and
real-life English is to create a world
on borders your line of sight is what
you can see physically in the world with
a vision of your eyes gaze is a fixed
intense conscious look for example she
gazed out into the horizon waiting for
the Sun to rise we need a new story a
new lens with which to address these
inconsistencies we need to scale up to
unleash a truly global citizenry
exchanging ideas beliefs goods and
services it has been said that empathy
rarely extends beyond our line of sight
and so perhaps it is by extending our
gaze using marvelous new storytelling
tools like virtual reality that we can
bridge divisions and bring worlds
together assuring in a form of radical
empathy to see the other as ourselves
where boundaries are dissolved in
compassion reigns supreme
massive transformation of consciousness
a software upgrade for mankind earthing
a new kind of global citizen we can do
this using marvelous news storytelling
tools like virtual reality that we can
bridge divisions and bring worlds
together to bridge is to join two
separate things in the same way that a
bridge joins two pieces of land for
example English is a way to bridge
communication between different
countries assuring and a form of radical
empathy to see the other as ourselves to
usher is to cause or mark the start of
something new for example we usher in
the new year with a party compassion
reign supreme
to reign is to rule over something for
example under the Kings leadership peace
reign for centuries - a software upgrade
for mankind birthing a new kind of
global citizen we can do this - birth is
to give birth or life and in this case
is talking about to birth a new
consciousness it has been said that
empathy rarely extends beyond our line
of sight and so perhaps it is by
extending our gaze using marvellous news
story
tools like virtual reality that we can
bridge divisions and bring worlds
together assuring in a form of radical
empathy to see the other as ourselves
where boundaries are dissolved in
compassion reigns supreme
massive transformation of consciousness
a software upgrade for mankind birthing
a new kind of global citizen we can do
this did you love this lesson then
remember to click here to join our free
three-part
mini course teaching you English with
your favorite TV series